à paris la polémique continue autour de
l'aso d'ouvéa précisément le ministre de
la défense monsieur jean pierre
chevènement affirmé aujourd'hui qu'il
était un peu trop facile de faire porter
le chapeau aux militaires qui ont donné
l'assaut écoutez le il m'apparaît bon à
part que toutes les possibilités de
médiation n'ont pas été utilisés je
parle de médiation avec les ravisseurs
par monsieur pons et que la décision
d'intervenir comporter de très gros
risque pour la vie des 23 gendarmes
retenus en otage quant à l'exécution de
l'opération de libération
trois jours avant le deuxième tour de
l'élection présidentielle elle était
extrêmement périlleuse il me paraît pour
ma part un peu trop facile de faire
porter le chapeau aux militaires qui ont
eu deux tués dans l'assaut
je souhaite que dans l'intérêt de la
france et de la démocratie
les préjugés n'en porte pas des
conclusions prématurées et injuste
sur la base de témoignages qui sont
forcément très fragile
dans une affaire où par ailleurs la
justice est saisie et doit faire son
travail